"Who are you?"
I would wake up in the morning,
andbefore I began my day,
I would meditate on this.
And with this question in mind,
I kept drawing.
I followed the line.
I let it lead the way.
And I drew myself out of a culture
that was only telling
me what I couldn't do.
The act of giving myself permission
to let go of all thoughts,
all fears,insecurities --
anything that would get in the way of
allowing myself to be completely me --
thatbecame my way of
experiencing freedom.
Over time, I began to create a
bold, confident space formyself,
a space that was all my own.
Initially, it was just my bedroom.
But that bedroom ended
up in "The New York Times,"
and suddenly, I was being seen and
known for this world I had created.
Drawing has taught me how
to create my own rules.
It has taught me to open my eyes to
see not only what is,
but what can be.